bonjour à tous de les poursuivre dans un
instant on dirait de l'hémicycle la
séance de questions cribles les
questions que vous le savez ce sont des
questions très précises que posent les
sénateurs un ministre le thème
aujourd'hui la politique énergétique
européenne et c'est donc le ministre de
l'ecologie philippe martin qui répond on
se retrouve tout de suite après ailleurs
au coeur des enjeux de la transition
énergétique se trouve l'équilibré
lectrique défi du mix énergétique dont
l'effacement hier la loi nome en a fixé
les principes et aujourd'hui la loi
brottes en pelouse les règles de mise en
oeuvre
il s'agit d'un dispositif exemplaire sur
le plan écologique économique et
industriel si une part du gisement est
attendu des particuliers une part tout
aussi importantes et des industriels
gros consommateurs pour lesquels le gain
économique peut être vital ce n'est pas
pour rien que l'allemagne s'est dotée
d'un fonds de 190 millions d'euros en
2013 avec une prévision de 320 millions
en 2014 au profit de son industrie
électro intensifs et que la pologne
travaillent actuellement à se doter
d'une capacité de 1000 mégawatts pour la
france qui dispose aujourd'hui du cadre
législatif nécessaire et des capacités
disponibles n'a toujours pas afficher
les moyens financiers qu'il entend
mobiliser alors qu'un grand nombre
d'industries et dans l'atteinte de ces
financements qui leur permettrait de
surcroît d'être des acteurs puissants et
utile de la transition énergétique
quels sont les engagements sur ce point
que le gouvernement entend prendre en
faveur de la filière industrielle
française
je remercie je passe la parole à
monsieur le ministre philippe martin
ministres écologie développement durable
et de l'énergie
oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sueur sénateur
jean-pierre vial je suis d'abord très
heureux d'être passé au crible par le
sénat pour la première fois de ma vie
la filière photovoltaïque française se
trouve dans une situation complexe
elle a subi les instabilité
réglementaire passé qui ont conduit à
une bulle spéculative n'aurait pas là
impudeur de vous rappeler sous quelle
majorité cette bulle a éclaté un nouveau
cadre été mis en place début 2013 j'ai
notamment annoncé le travail sur un
cahier des charges pour le lancement
début 2014 un nouvel appel pour les
installations de plus de 250 kilowatts
ces modalités de soutien se poursuivront
pour maintenir le rythme de déploiement
à l'échelle métropolitaine
il faut pouvoir maintenir une cadence
raisonnable afin de s'inscrire dans la
durée
à l'avenir le soutien au photovoltaïque
intégrera aussi les évolutions des
modalités de soutien est le résultat des
travaux de prospective sur ce que sera
le marché photovoltaïque dans quelques
années
c'est essentiel si l'on veut faire les
bons choix structurelles il faut aussi
prendre en compte les contraintes
financières car le déploiement des nerfs
vous le savez ce sont les commentaires
les consommateurs qui ne supportent
ensemble nous devons donc viser à
l'optimalité économique du système
vous mettez en avant le fait qu'en 2013
nous n'allons pas atteindre les 1000
mégawatts et vous avez raison mais c'est
la conséquence directe de la bulle
spéculative sur le photovoltaïque en
effet les projets photovoltaïques met en
moyenne 12 à 18 mois pour se raccorder
jusqu'à 24 mois en moyenne pour les
grandes installations
ainsi les projets raccordé au second
promesse de 2013 sont entrés en file
d'attende pendant le moratoire
les mesures d'urgence prises par le
gouvernement en début de cette année se
traduiront dans les raccordements à
partir de 2014 mais d'ores et déjà je
puis vous dire que nous relevons une
certaine reprise avec une augmentation
de plus de 100% des raccordements au
troisième trimestre de 2013 par rapport
au trimestre précédent
concernant votre seconde question la
seconde partie les dispositifs
d'effacement le cadre établi notamment
dans le cadre de la loi brottes que
votre groupe n'a malheureusement pas
soutenu rt travaille par ailleurs à la
conception de nouveaux produits
innovants valorisables par les
industriels
grâce à tous ces dispositifs les
industriels deviennent de plus en plus
acteurs de leur consommation d
entreprise spécialiste dans le domaine
de l'effacement afin de faire baisser
les factures d'électricité des
industriels en 2013 c'est plus de 1200
mégawatts qui sont actionnable selon
energy pool que vous connaissez bien
pour les industriels cela pourra se
traduire par des baisses significatives
de factures mon cabinet travaille
étroitement avec les effaceurs pour
veiller à ce que les textes
réglementaires permettent le
développement effectif de l'effacement
car entre effacement et production je
préfère bien sur l'effacement surtout
cher monsieur le ministre deux minutes
pour la réponse c'est la première
question crible il nous sera beaucoup
pardonné mais nous serons vigilants sur
les suivantes la parole et à monsieur
vial pour la réplique oui monsieur nice
j'ai bien sûr la première question
entendu votre réponse également les
engagements sur les objectifs que vous
avez rappelé puis je cité en exemple qui
est quand même une référence qui sera
d'ailleurs je crois un test pour tous
c'est la situation de l'entreprise bosch
à vénissieux sur lequel très sincèrement
je sais que beaucoup d'opérateurs
beaucoup de grands cabinets manifeste
une position très réservé je pense que
c'est un bon dossier sur lequel tester
cette filière enfin sur le deuxième
point j'ai noté effectivement là aussi
votre intérêt pour l'effacement
je me permets de citer un exemple
d'actualité c'était la reprise durant
cet été de groupe aluminium rio tinto à
saint jean de maurienne qui a été repris
par un groupe allemand trimestre dont le
modèle a justement montrer la pertinence
qu'il avait de la bonne utilisation de
l'énergie et notamment de ce dispositif
d'effacement merci je passe la parole à
monsieur aymeri de montesquiou pour le
groupe u10 uc merci monsieur le
président je préside à monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
en décembre 2008 un accord a été ratifié
par les membres de l'union permettant la
réalisation de l'objectif des 3 x 20 à
l'horizon 2020 c'est-à-dire réduction de
20 % des mises émissions de co2
augmentation de la part des énergies
renouvelables dans le mix énergétique
européen jusqu'à au moins 20%
accroissement de l'efficacité
énergétique de 20%
c est une tâche ardue car chaque pays
poursuivait une politique énergétique
différentes
cinq ans plus tard qu'en est il de cette
convergence
certes les réseaux sont plus à même
aujourd'hui de mutualiser les cris cité
dans l'union européenne
si on constate des progrès réalisés en
matière d'économie d'énergie et de
développement des énergies renouvelables
on constate une divergence profonde
entre les politiques énergétiques
le renoncement de l'allemagne au nuc
est reconduit ce pays a augmenté très
fortement sa consommation de charbon de
l'inite les conséquences en sont
désastreuses pour l'environnement
l'italie et l'espagne refuse elle aussi
l'énergie nucléaire la france annoncent
vouloir baisser la part du nucléaire
dans son bouquet énergétique mais
cherche à prolonger la vie de ses
centrales de 10 ans décision ne
permettant plus de ramener à 50 % d'ici
2020 la part du nucléaire dans la
production d'électricité
de leur côté la grande-bretagne et la
finlande développe le nucléaire grâce à
des entreprises françaises les
politiques énergétiques des manques de
l'union sont donc totalement divergentes
elle s'accorde néanmoins sur
l'importance du développement les
énergies renouvelables quelles actions
comptez vous mettre en oeuvre pour faire
converger ces politiques nationales afin
de respecter l'accord de 2008
merci la parole est à monsieur philippe
martin pour deux minutes
monsieur le sénateur aymeri de
montesquiou merci pour votre question
qui souligne à juste titre l'importance
du paquet énergie climat adopté en 2008
s'ouvre est toutefois vous rappeler que
la france je pense que vous ne me
contredirez pas sur ce point toujours
été et reste attaché aussi au respect de
la souveraineté de chaque état
chaque état doit pouvoir continuer à
faire en toute autonomie ses choix
énergétiques en particulier son choix de
mix énergétique c'est important pour des
raisons de principe mais aussi pour des
raisons historiques et géographiques
chaque état a sa propre histoire
énergétique ou son héritage
cela doit être pris en compte et
respecté notre pleine adhésion car
européen ne peut et ne doit pas s'y fait
un abandon de notre souveraineté
énergétique
c'est pourquoi aussi je recommandais une
certaine réserve lorsqu'il s'agit de
juger les choix des autres pays
le précédent gouvernement avait beaucoup
critiqué le choix de l'allemagne de
sortir du nucléaire
ce n'est pas notre choix nous avons fait
le choix d'un rééquilibrage de notre mix
énergétique mais vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur il y a des
divergences et elles perdureront même si
le président de la république a tenu à
inscrire à l'ordre du jour du conseil
européen qui se tiendra au mois de mars
la question de l'europe de l'énergie qui
manquent
cruellement à l'ensemble européen à cet
égard la politique européenne de
l'énergie a offert quand même un cadre
stimulant
il a permis par exemple d'augmenter de
cinq points la part des nerfs dans le
mix énergétique européen en six ans qui
atteignait ainsi 13 % en 2011
c'est un gage de crédibilité sur le plan
de notre diplomatie environnementale
mais aussi et surtout un cadre favorable
qu'il faudra renouveler au delà de 2020
pour la croissance nécessaire d'une
nouvelle économie verte
j'ai gagné 30 secondes monsieur le
président merci ce nous allons récupérer
ce que vous deviez merci monsieur de
montesquiou j'ai re de contacter
monsieur ministère compatriotes que
aujourd'hui nous avons quelques
convergences et que votre tâche est
ardue
il est vrai que il n'ya pas de
convergence originel et qu'à partir de
choix nationaux très différent on ne
peut avoir une politique
d'approvisionnement commune ce qui est
un point me semble-t-il stratégique très
important
d'autre part la politique de la
commission a privilégié le démantèlement
des grands groupes ceux qui les
fragilisent cette politique de la
commission est ancienne est-ce que vous
l'approuvez mais est ce que vous
pourriez nous indiquer une voie qui
pourrait faire converger ces politiques
je sais qu'il ya la subsidiarité que
chacun a sa brique nationale mais sa
fragile l'entité européenne et je crois
qu'il faut prendre une décision dans ce
conte 6/2 je me réjouis que le président
honored aimé l'énergie à l'ordre du jour
du prochain conseil
merci mais nous allons interrompre cet
échange entre gasco pour passer la
parole à monsieur michel teston merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chères et chers collègues le
développement des énergies renouvelables
création de petites unités de production
d'énergie
c'est une chance pour le développement
économique des territoires ruraux mais
aussi pour les collectivités
territoriales de plus en plus impliqué
en matière de politique énergétique
nos concitoyens consomme ainsi l'énergie
produite par ces petites unités de
production et plus seulement par les
grandes
ce qui contribue au maintien voire au
développement de l'emploi local
il est donc essentiel que notre nation
et l'union européenne continue non
seulement à soutenir l'investissement
dans les énergies renouvelables
mais que ce soit aussi reconnu le rôle
essentiel des collectivités locales dans
la réussite de la transition énergétique
et dans le pilotage de la stratégie de
la stratégie énergétique du territoire
or deux grands énergéticiens européens
plaident pour un changement de politique
européenne en demandant le développement
de centrales à gaz et la fin des
subventions à certaines énergies
renouvelables en outre des états membres
se sont lancés dans l'exploitation de
grandes infrastructures d'énergies
carbonées
dans ce contexte il est à craindre que
la politique énergétique européenne
soirée orientée de manière moins
favorable
un mix énergétique équilibré sur le
ministre ma question est simple
existe-t-il un risque de réorientation
de la politique énergétique européenne
et pourriez-vous éventuellement nous
préciser votre appréciation sur l'impact
réel de la déclaration de ces grands
énergéticiens sur ministre de l'écologie
et du développement durable ainsi que de
l'industrie des autres états membres
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président monsieur sénateur michel
teston vous rappeler juste titre
l'importance qu'il y a de rester
ambitieux en matière de développement
des énergies renouvelables au niveau
français et européen
et vous avez raison je vous confirme que
pour le gouvernement la transition
énergétique se fera avec les énergies
renouvelables l'objectif fixé par le
président de la république d'un
rééquilibrage de notre mix de 75 à 50%
d'électricité d'origine nucléaire à
l'horizon de 2025 doit se faire avec le
déploiement d'énergie renouvelable
décarbonés et créatrice d'emplois
je partage aussi certaines des solutions
proposées auquel d'ailleurs le
gouvernement a déjà commencé le travail
et la nécessité de relever le prix du
carbone afin de restaurer la rentabilité
des projets industriels à faibles
émissions de carbone c'est la réforme en
cours dit du black loading et je me
réjouis que la chancelière merkel est
officiellement apporté son soutien à
cette réforme cette semaine la nécessité
de mettre en place
des mécanismes de gestion des phénomènes
d'intermittence et le pointe dans le
respect des règles de marché
la nécessité d'accompagner les objectifs
de réduction des gaz à effet de serre et
de développement des er d'un programme
d'adaptation progressive et
d'harmonisation européenne des
politiques de soutien aux énergies
renouvelables
prenant en compte la maturité
respectives de chaque énergie
vous avez donc raison aux sénateurs
d'insister sur la nécessité d' amplifier
nos efforts pour le développement des
énergies renouvelables pour placer la
france sur la voie de l'excellence
environnementale
ce sont bien nos territoires qui sont en
première ligne et l'europe est notre
meilleur allié
c'est pourquoi je plaiderai pour une
ambition renforcée en matière de
politique européenne de l'énergie
ce débat devrait notamment aboutir lors
du conseil que j'évoquais à l'instant en
mars 2014 points mis à l'ordre du jour à
l'initiative du président de la
république françois hollande vous pouvez
donc compter sur le président de la
république et sur l'ensemble du
gouvernement pour soutenir les idées
vous avez développé dans votre question
merci mon cher collègue si vous
souhaitez réagir mais merci monsieur le
ministre de votre réponse
il est vraisemblable que la consommation
mondiale d'énergie augmentera très
fortement au cours des prochaines années
alors pour relever ce défi le recours
aux énergies renouvelables apparaît
incontestablement comme une solution
adaptée j'approuve donc votre volonté
monsieur le ministre de ne pas
réorienter la politique énergétique
européenne réorientation qui est demandé
par un certain nombre de grands
énergéticiens européens
toutefois il conviendra d'être à la fois
vigilant réactif
je suis intimement convaincu que vous le
serez merci la parole à présent à mieux
mireille cherche pour le groupe crc
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en janvier
2013 nous avions déjà souhaité porter en
débat
l'avenir des concessions des grands
barrages et les installations
hydroélectriques patrimoine énergétique
française stratégique tant d'un point de
vue industriel et agricole que social
environnemental et d'aménagement du
territoire
le gouvernement avait alors souhaité
attendre les conclusions du rapport de
la députée marie noëlle battistel mais
début septembre
et sans attendre la présentation du
rapport vous avez souhaité monsieur le
ministre
avec vos collègues de l'économie et des
finances et du budget que soit enclenché
la procédure d'appel d'offres jugeant
qu'elles constituaient je vous cite la
solution juridique la plus robuste pour
optimiser le patrimoine national de
l'hydroélectricité or madame baptiste
elle explique dans son rapport que cette
procédure présente un danger pour la
sûreté des usagers et la sécurité
d'approvisionnement je la cite va
entraîner une hausse mécanique du prix
de l'électricité ne donne pas les
garanties suffisantes aux acteurs locaux
pour les ducs différents usages de l'eau
et va entraîner inévitablement des
destructions d'emplois le président
hollande dit vouloir relancer la
communauté européenne de l'énergie afin
de coordonner tous les efforts pour les
énergies renouvelables
ce que nous salon or nous le savons la
production hydraulique est la forme
d'énergie la plus flexible est l'une des
moins polluantes
un barrage peut en quelques minutes
passer d'une production nul à sa pleine
puissance
l'hydroélectricité est un outil central
pour l'équilibré du réseau électrique et
à ce titre les stations de transfert
d'énergie par pompage doivent être
développées en effet dans le cas du
développement des énergies renouvelables
forcément intermittente ce type
d'ouvragé le seul qui permettent le
stockage de l'énergie produit d'ailleurs
pendant les heures creuses
comment monsieur le ministre pouvait
vous concilier l'inconciliable
d'un côté la mise en concurrence et donc
la privatisation de la production
énergétique hydraulique de la france et
de l'autre le projet d'une communauté
européenne qui garantissent notre
indépendance énergétique et le droit
d'accès à l'énergie pour tous les
citoyens un tarif abordable
comment enfin pouvez vous dire que
l'emploi est la priorité du gouvernement
alors que vous mettez des centaines
d'emplois dans de très nombreuses
vallées de montagne en danger par la
mise en concurrence des concessions
hydrauliques
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice l'hydroélectricité est une
énergie décentralisée qui s'inscrit dans
la volonté de développer massivement des
énergies renouvelables ancré dans les
territoires comme vous l'avez dit qu'ils
génèrent des emplois non délocalisables
c'est également un patrimoine national
les élus de montagne sont très attachés
notamment à l'égard duquel le
gouvernement a un devoir de préservation
et de bonne gestion
nous devons assurer le renouvellement
des concessions qui sont échouées ou qui
arriveront à échéance dans les
prochaines années et ceux ci est une
obligation qui nous est faite par la loi
c'est pour éclairer le gouvernement dans
ses choix que la commission des affaires
économiques de l'assemblée a confié à
madame battistel et monsieur straumann
une mission consistant à explorer des
différents scénarios possibles le
renouvellement des concessions
s'effectuera évidemment dans le respect
du droit
c'est ce que le gouvernement a voulu
réaffirmer dans la réponse qu'il a fait
un référé qui lui avait transmis la cour
des comptes dans un calendrier reste un
et je tiens à vous dire une chose c'est
qu'une réponse à la cour des comptes
n'est pas l'affirmation d'une politique
sur le sujet l'affirmation de la
politique viendra après le débat que
nous allons continuer d'avoir avec
madame battistel avec monsieur straumann
avec les sénateurs pour effectivement
regarder cet héritage mais je le dis ici
ce sont ceux dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui c'est d'une politique de
l'hydroélectricité en france dans cette
politique d'hydroélectricité nous devons
être vigilants à plusieurs points les
industries électro entend intensive
nous devons donner le places nouvelles
et importantes aux collectivités
territoriales
la conséquence de la mise en concurrence
sur les personnels doit être prise en
compte
une attention particulière doit être
portée à la continuité écologique et à
la performance environnementale dans la
gestion des barrages
je n'oublie pas enfin la dimension des
différents usages de l'eau tiens à vous
rassurer sur ce point madame la
sénatrice
le gouvernement prendra en compte les
résultats de l'expertisé diligentée par
la commission des affaires économiques
de l'assemblée
elle prendra en compte l'avis des
sénateurs et je suis ouvert je le dis
ici à ce que nous puissions y travailler
ensemble avant de prendre des décisions
définitives
merci en réponse nous sommes la
présidente
andy david
et ça marche pardon merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre votre
réponse à peine une partie de nos
craintes et j'ai bien entendu que vous
avez l'intention de lancer cette
discussion avec le rapport à la suite du
rapport de madame battistel de lancer
cette discussion aussi avec les
sénateurs et nous nous en réjouissons
car en effet le rapport de madame
baptiste elle propose des pistes
alternatives à la simple mise en
concurrence piste donc de ce rapport qui
mérite incontestablement d'être prises
en considération puisqu'elles prennent
aussi en compte la participation des
salariés du sac du secteur et je vous ai
bien entendu cet après midi monsieur le
ministre et je vous ai également bien
écouter à coutrai lors du congrès des
élus de la montagne
puisqu'en tant élus iséroise je connais
bien
également ces problématiques de de
l'hydroélectricité vous dites vouloir
soutenir donc l'hydroélectricité et les
industriels électro intensifs et vous
dites également que la politique
énergétique doit être refondée en
direction des usagers à travers un
service public de l'énergie et donc les
collectivités doivent prendre toute leur
place toute leur place c'est une très
bonne proposition monsieur ministre il
vous importe donc de ne pas céder à
l'europe quant à la libéralisation de ce
secteur et surtout de tenir bon dans le
maintien des tarifs réglementés merci
merci la parole à un ronan dantec pour
le groupe écologiste
monsieur monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
dans un projet de communication dont
nous avons eu quelques échos
communication intitulée achevé le marché
intérieur de l'électricité et tirer le
meilleur parti de l'intervention
publique
la commission européenne fait notamment
part de son inquiétude concernant la
création de 28 marché de capacités
nationaux elle indique que ces marchés
qui visent à assurer le maintien d'une
capacité de production électrique
suffisante pour faire face aux pointes
de consommation doit être considéré par
les états membres comme un dernier
recours
les habitants plutôt donc à renforcer
les interconnexions frontières et à
coopérer entre régionalement pour
étudier la possibilité de mettre en
oeuvre des mécanismes transfrontalier
conformément à la loi nome rte le réseau
de transport d'électricité et la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
travaille actuellement à la définition
des règles du marché de capacités
français qui devrait être opérationnelle
d'ici 2015 2016
monsieur le ministre ma question est
donc très simple comment construis ton
le marché de capacités européen partir
de là comment crée-t-on de la cohérence
entre des marges nationale et
inquiétudes européennes
vous avez déclaré mardi lors du colloque
de l'union française de l'électricité
qu'un important travail est encore avec
l'allemagne pour l'élargissement du
système de capacités français pouvaient
nous donc nous garantir que le
calendrier choisi en france est
compatible avec un éventuel futur
mécanisme européen ou à minima avec un
mécanisme commun aux pays interconnecté
avec la france et donc pas seulement
l'allemagne aussi le benelux la suisse
ou l'espagne
ramona creux paru en juillet montrent
que les couplages de marché entre la
france le benelux et l'allemagne ont
déjà permis depuis fin 2010 d'économiser
environ 50 millions d'euros par an en
coût d'approvisionnement et on attend
régulièrement que la mise en place d'un
mécanisme marché européen unique
réduirait de moitié
l'investissement nécessaire en capacité
décliner ensuite sur les échelles
nationale outre sa contribution à la
sécurité d'approvisionnement et à la
baisse du prix de gros un mécanisme
européen lié au renforcement des
interconnexions sera également une
mesure majeure de l'accompagnement du
développement des énergies renouvelables
en europe
nous vous remercions donc monsieur le
ministre de nous confirmer que les
décisions prises en france s'inscriront
bien dans la définition de cet outil
stratégique de la future communauté
européenne de l'énergie
merci n'a pas la parole à monsieur le
ministre monsieur le sénateur ronan
dantec et et ses supporters le mécanisme
français est un mécanisme innovant pour
inciter au développement de nouvelles
capacités de production ou d'effacement
lorsque la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement est menacée il est
neutre technologiquement et permet de ne
pas créer les distorsions sur le marché
de l'énergie le dispositif français un
site en particulier au développement des
capacités d'effacement et leur ouvre les
mêmes droits qu'aux capacités de
production ce dispositif sera mis en
oeuvre à compter de 2016
selon les grands principes du mécanisme
de capacités définies par le décret du
14 décembre 2012 une consultation sur
les règles précises est actuellement
menée par rte et implique l'ensemble des
acteurs du marché de l'électricité dans
le même temps la france participe
activement aux réflexions européenne
c'est ce que vous évoquez sur
l'articulation des différents mécanismes
au niveau européen
et de ce point de vue la publication par
la commission européenne de lignes
directrices prévu dans les prochaines
semaines est une initiative bienvenue
que la france suivra avec attention il
ne comporte aucune aide d'état car la
valeur des incapacités et relevé par un
mécanisme de marché en ce qui concerne
ce mécanisme innovant le 14 octobre 2013
la commission européenne a adopté une
liste de 248 projets clés dans le
domaine des infrastructures énergétiques
et la france est concernée par neuf
projets dans le secteur du gaz et six
projets dans le secteur de l'électricité
le développement des interconnexions est
une condition indispensable à
l'établissement d'un marché intérieur de
l'électricité et du gaz
ces interconnexions permettront
d'assurer une meilleure convergence des
prix une meilleure sécurité
d'approvisionnement une bonne insertion
des énergies renouvelables
les grandes règles les régissant sur le
code des réseaux élément clé dans la
construction de marché intérieur
européen de l'électricité et du gaz
merci monsieur ronan dantec wii 2 2 3
remarque je remercie d'abord monsieur le
ministre d'avoir insisté sur la question
de l'effacement sur lequel j'étais peu
revenu dans mes deux minutes c'est
effectivement une des questions
centrales on insiste beaucoup trop sur
la nécessité de production
supplémentaire mais pour ceux qui
continuent d'agiter le spectre du black
out je crois qu'effectivement d'avoir
des mécanismes d'effacement efficace
sera une des réponses clé demain à ce
marché intégré européen donc je crois
que c'est un point important et je
voudrais en conclusion est peut-être en
écho à ce qu'a dit michel teston insisté
sur le fait que ces grands industriels
européens de l'énergie qui ont publié
cette tribune ne s'attaque pas aux
énergies renouvelables disent
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la désorganisation
à l'échelle européenne du marché
l'énergie qui est en cause et insiste
comme nous sur deux points essentiels la
remontée de la tonne co2 qui est un
point central
et effectivement ce mécanisme de marché
européen deux capacités et ses ces
points-là qui permettront demain un
développement rationnel et rapide des
énergies renouvelables
merci la parole à présent vraiment
valent pour le groupe rds président
raymond vall merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le groupe rdse et vous le savez très
attentive aux questions énergétiques
notre position est connue l'indépendance
énergétique de la france et plus
largement celle de l'union européenne
est un objectif essentiel auquel nous
devons accorder une attention
prioritaire
or l'europe est en situation de forte
dépendance avec une facture annuelle
d'environ 350 milliards d'euros
facture qui ne va que s'accroître il est
donc impératif d'engager le pays dans
l'élaboration d'un scénario énergétique
ambitieux efficace et solidaire pour
pouvoir diversifier nos sources
d'énergie et garantir nos
approvisionnements et ceci peut-être en
tenant compte des particularités de nos
pays géographiques climatiques etc
cela signifie en particulier que nous
devons promouvoir nos filières
d'excellence que ce soit pour le
nucléaire ou les énergies renouvelables
et favoriser encore plus que nous
n'avons jamais fait la sobriété
énergétique et l'efficacité dans tous
les secteurs d'activité qui en sont gros
consommateurs tels que le bâtiment et
les transports
mais face à ces objectifs et cela a été
rappelé tout à l'heure nous observons
des stratégies très individuelle
anarchique l'allemagne qui se désengage
du nucléaire et qui met à mal notre
filière gas parce que évidemment nous ne
supportons pas la comparaison des prix
le gaz français et trois fois plus cher
que le gaz américain et deux fois plus
cher que le gaz allemand donc nous avons
là un déséquilibre qui certes respecte
l'indépendance de ce pays mais qui a un
impact sur notre propre pays enfin je
veux dire que cela a été déjà dit
aujourd'hui nos industriels attendent
évidemment avoir d'avoir sur ce plan là
donc une hommes politiques qu'ils soient
clarifiées simplifiée et que nous
puissions aussi nous engager dans cette
création d'emplois qui représente 35
cents mille emplois en europe sans
rougir d'ailleurs des comparaisons car
je vous le rappelle le par habitant nos
émissions de co2 sont très sensiblement
inférieure à celle de l'allemagne 6 5 6
tonnes par habitant au lieu de 9,6 en
2011 dont monsieur le ministre bien sûr
comme tous les autres intervenants
nous attendons de savoir quelle est la
politique le gouvernement compte
d'engager pour arriver
cette harmonisation au niveau européen
qui nous paraît indispensable
monsieur le ministre bien monsieur le
sénateur raymond vall du gers
j'aurais vu tous mes amis gascon j'ai
dit ce que je pensais des divergences
observées sur le marché européen
l'énergie elles sont l'héritage de
l'histoire qui nous faut mieux
appréhender afin de réussir ensemble à
lutter efficacement contre le changement
le dérèglement climatique et prendre le
tournant de l'économie verte
votre question me donne l'occasion de
préciser nos efforts dans le domaine des
énergies renouvelables au plan européen
je partage votre avis selon lequel les
investissements réalisés par nos
entreprises dans ce domaine doivent
continuer d'être soutenu la commission
européenne a soumis au printemps dernier
un livre blanc sur le futur paquet
énergie climat
en réponse le gouvernement a indiqué
qu'il était favorable à la définition
d'un objectif de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet serre de -40% 2030 et
dans un second temps d'un objectif nerfs
et d'un objectif d'économies d'énergie
le calendrier pour aller vers l'adoption
de ce futur paquet est désormais le
suivant lors du dernier conseil européen
consacré l'énergie le 22 mai dernier les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement ont
décidé de se donner rendez vous en mars
2014 pour examiner la question du futur
paquet climat énergie cette date de mars
2014 sera donc importante
il y aura des divergences nos amis
britanniques ne sont pas favorables un
objectif sur les nerfs par exemple il y
a aussi des discussions intéressantes
avec nos partenaires polonais et le
groupe de pays dits devise grade qui
sont très réservés sur l'opportunité
d'adopter rapidement un objectif de
réduction de gaz à effet serre pour 2030
or comme vous le soulignez nos
entreprises ont besoin de visibilité et
l'europe ne peut pas attendre pour fixer
un cap ambitieux au delà nous avons la
conférence pour le climat qui aura lieu
à paris fin 2015 et la france et
l'europe doivent être exemplaires s'ils
veulent obtenir un accord universel et
contraignant ce qui est l'objectif si on
veut pas obtenir une augmentation de la
température de 2 degrés à la fin de ce
siècle
c'est l'engagement de la france c'est
l'engagement de l'europe c'est
l'engagement que je porte
merci monsieur le président le vol
merci monsieur le président monsieur
mini je vous remercie de votre réponse
et nous constatons tous votre forte
motivation je sais que votre tâche n'est
pas facile et donc sont là pour vous
soutenir je voudrais simplement vous
dire que il y à des aberrations
économiques aujourd'hui l'électricité
est peut-être le seul produit qui peut
avoir un prix négatifs dont je crois que
face à une telle situation nous devons
de trouver des parades car l'argent
public de chaque pays est engagé à perte
ce qui paraît quand même quelque chose
d'aberrant dans les moments que nous
connaissons et enfin je voudrais vous
dire que toute façon aujourd'hui la
garantie de prix d'achat n'a plus aucune
forme de raison de ne pas être revu
compte tenu qu'à certains moments par
exemple l'été dernier l'allemagne a
produit plus de la moitié de ses besoins
en électricité avec des sources
d'énergie renouvelables donc il faut
absolument faire quelque chose je vous
remercie de votre motivation très bien
la parole est un jean claude lenoir pour
le groupe m merci et son président
monsieur le ministre pour accéder au
pouvoir françois hollande a fait un
cadeau très coûteux aux écologistes
il a indiqué qu'il allait fermer la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim vous
même à peine nommé ministre
vous l'avez fait une déclaration
retentissant dans le journal du dimanche
du 21 juillet je fermerai fessenheim
avant la fin de 2016
alors monsieur mis cette décision si
elle était menée à bien et absurde
d'abord parce que fessenheim produit
beaucoup d'électricité 88 % des besoins
de l'alsace 3 % des besoins de la france
notre part fessenheim apporte 400 à 500
millions d'euros de recettes à edf fait
travailler 800 salariés directement et
un peu plus de 1000 1 directement
j'ajoute que pour mener à bien cette
entreprise monsieur le ministre il faut
remplir un certain nombre de conditions
d'abord ce n'est pas le gouvernement qui
pilotent fessenheim
ce n'est pas le gouvernement qui pilote
une centrale nucléaire une centrale
nucléaire est piloté par un exploitant
sous le contrôle de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire
or l'autorité a autorisé il y a peu de
temps
edf à poursuivre l'exploitation de
fessenheim pendant 10 ans sous réserve
d'un certain nombre de travaux qui sont
pour l'essentiel terminées et
seront complètement achevés d'ici à la
fin de décembre 2013
je rappelle d'autre part que fessenheim
n'est pas la seule propriété d'edf aux
deux tiers
l'autre tiers est partagé entre eux mdw
allemand et un consortium suisse alors
la fermeture de fessenheim expose
dangereusement la france d'abord nous
allons manquer d'électricité
deuxièmement nous allons devoir verser
nous allons devoir verser des
dédommagements à ceux qui sont avec edf
propriétaire de la centrale
troisièmement vous contrevenez à ce qu'a
décidé l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
quatrièmement rien aujourd'hui dans la
loi ne permet à un gouvernement de se
substituer à ceux qui gèrent une
centrale nucléaire
merci pour la réponse de la porterez à
ces questions importantes
très bien alors monsieur philippe martin
pour répondre monsieur le noir et le
président de la république et le premier
ils sont fixés une méthode et des
objectifs
la méthode c'est la diversification
notre mix les objectifs c'est une
réduction de la part du nucléaire à 50%
une réduction de notre consommation
finale d'énergie de 50% à l'horizon 2050
une réduction de 30 % de notre
consommation d'énergie fossile et 23 %
d'énergie d'origine renouvelable en 2020
ce sénateur les décisions à venir sur la
gestion du parc nucléaire de la france
devront être compatibles avec cette
méthode et ses objectifs pour l'avenir
pour l'ensemble du parc nucléaire les
décisions devront être prises sous
réserve bien sûr de l'avis de l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire mais monsieur le
noir c'est ce qui nous différencie
vous vous n'aimez pas que l'état soit
stratèges vous laissez à edf est une
autorité de sûreté le soin de dire les
choses
nous ce que nous voulons c'est ramener
l'état dans le rôle qui doit être le
sien il y à l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui peut effectivement donner
son avis pour raisons sûreté il y adf
qui peut donner son avis pour des
raisons économiques et il y à l'état qui
doit effectivement donné est le garant
de la stratégie énergétique et c'est la
raison pour laquelle monsieur le noir je
vous confirme que dans la loi de
transition énergétique
il y aura ce retour de l'état stratège
et que oui que vous le vouliez ou non il
y aura bien une fermeture de fessenheim
à la fin 2016
alors s'ils le souhaitent la réplique
promotionner noir monsieur le ministre
vous donne rendez vous fin 2007 vous
n'aurez pas fermer la centrale de
fessenheim
vous pouvez éventuellement l'arrêter en
ne nourrissons pas la centrale de
combustible mais je vous rappelle que
les règles qui s'appliquent aux ti de la
sûreté nucléaire ne permettrait pas à
l'exploitant de conserver une centrale
qui ne fonctionnerait pas au delà de
deux ans il faut alors se soumettre à
des règles qui sont précises dans la loi
et qui confie à l'asn non pas le soin de
donner des avis nous seuls nice mais de
prendre des décisions dans cette affaire
puisqu'on parle de la politique
européenne de l'énergie
je rappelle une chose votre référence
c'est l'allemagne qui est actuellement
en train d'augmenter la production
d'électricité à partir de charbon de
limites du charbon qui vient des états
unis
actuellement le problème du co2 le
problème des gaz à effet de serre il
n'est pas en france grâce au nucléaire
il est en allemagne alors monsieur le
ministre mettait toute la fougue dont je
sais que vous êtes capables pour
convaincre les allemands d'arrêter la
production d'électricité à partir de
charbon
merci n'a pas en l'état à notre collègue
roland courteau pour le groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre il est important que l'union
européenne puisse en faire apparaître
comme le moteur de projets positifs pour
ses citoyens et non pas simplement comme
un producteur de normes avec troubles
obsessionnels de la concurrence comme le
dirait daniel ramoune la communauté
européenne de l'énergie
je veux mettre en oeuvre le président de
la république doit non favoriser
l'identification des sujets sur lesquels
l'apport de l'europe sera visible de
tous deux principes à cet égard soutenir
la maîtrise des coudes pour les citoyens
qui consacrent une part croissante de
leur budget à la consommation d'énergie
et privilégier des activités d'avenir
créatrice d'emplois les choix faits pour
chaque pays paraissent difficiles à
concilier concernant les énergies
fossiles mais il est un domaine où un
terrain d'entente
peut-être trouvé pour une action commune
je veux parler du développement des
énergies renouvelables
or la commission européenne a
semble-t-il travailler sur une révision
des raies
encadrant les aides publiques au secteur
énergétique
quelle position la france va-t-elle
retenir pour la définition d'un nouveau
cadre européen des énergies
renouvelables en particulier
envisage-t-on de relance et oppressif du
tarif d'achat pour retenir uniquement la
procédure d'appel d'offres
on sait bien que le mécanisme du tarif
d'achat est plus difficile à piloter
pour les pouvoirs publics et qu'il a
connu des dérives en termes de coude
dans le passé j'attire toutefois à votre
attention sur les conséquences que tel
choix pourrait avoir sur l'organisation
du secteur notamment en termes d'emploi
et de territorialisation car les appels
d'offres favorisait générale les grandes
entreprises
il ne faudrait donc pas mettre en
difficulté les petites unités locales de
production d'énergie renouvelable car
elles sont essentielles au développement
de notre consommation et de l'autonomie
énergétique des territoires je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole oui monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur courteau
la diversification de notre mix
électrique est un enjeu d'indépendance
énergétique pour la france et le
développement des er un levier pour
créer des emplois dans nos territoires
c'est la déclaration du président de la
république lors de la deuxième
conférence environnementale
c'est l'un des moyens qui nous
permettront de mettre tous les atouts de
notre côté pour atteindre les objectifs
climatiques ambitieux fixés par le chef
de l'état les énergies renouvelables
électriques sont aujourd'hui sous le feu
des projecteurs européen je partage une
partie du diagnostic fait par certains
énergéticiens selon lequel les
dispositifs des choses nerfs ne sont
plus adaptés et doivent évoluer
mais attention aux idées reçues aux
conclusions active c'est pour cela comme
vous l'avez rappelé que j'ai décidé le
lancement d'un travail pour analyser les
problèmes actuels et les solutions
possibles en tout état de cause quelle
que soit l'évolution elle sera
progressive et non rétroactive
le président de la république l'a
clairement posée lors de la deuxième
conférence
il nous faut mettre en place un cadre
réglementaire stable
un cadre fiscal claire des mécanismes de
soutien vertueux et faire baisser les
coûts de production
aujourd'hui le vrai problème pour les
énergies renouvelables réside dans
l'absence de lien entre leur production
et les contraintes du réseau électrique
qui
ces sites à chaque instant une égalité
entre production et consommation
comme je les ai déjà dit il n'ya
aujourd'hui rien d'arrêté la meilleure
solution pour porter le développement
notre bouquet d'énergies renouvelables
réside sans doute dans une pluralité les
systèmes de soutien adapté à chaque
filière
et comme vous je ne souhaite pas voir
les petits acteurs disparaître car les
énergies renouvelables ont une dimension
locale très importante
cette dimension sera bien évidemment
prise en compte dans la réflexion qui va
démarrer la démarche engagée est
nécessaire pour garantir la durabilité
et l'optima bilité du développement des
nerfs nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre lors de la discussion du projet
de loi sur la transition énergétique de
l'année prochaine et je vous donne
rendez vous merci
roland courteau merci monsieur le
ministre de votre réponse soyez
toutefois vigilants par rapport au
maintien et au développement des petites
unités locales de production
deux autres remarque la transition
énergétique de l'europe devra se faire
avec un bouquet l'hérétique varié en
termes de sources d'énergie certes mais
aussi en articulant les échelles locales
nationales et européennes quant aux
politiques de soutien aux énergies
renouvelables
elles devront aussi comporter un volet
consacré aux réseaux aux réseaux comme
l'a proposé la commission européenne il
faudra me relier les différents pays
afin d'amener l'électricité produite
là où elle peut être consommée la
coopération entre les opérateurs de
réseaux de chaque pays sera donc
essentiel afin d'éviter la construction
en trop grand nombre de centrales qui ne
fonctionnerait que quelques heures par
an merci je passe la parole à présent
monsieur jean françois husson pour le
groupe ump
oui monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues l'énergie est un des sujets
fondateur de l'union européenne que ce
au travers de la communauté européenne
du charbon et de l'acier ou de la
communauté européenne de l'énergie
atomique
cela répondait à cette belle ambition de
jean monnet pour construire l'europe je
cite m les moyens de la guerre au
service de la paix l'énergie est
aujourd'hui encore un enjeu majeur du
dessein européen
que ce soit à travers la dépendance
énergétique les échanges commerce
show hors communauté européenne la
question de la sécurité des
approvisionnements ou des énergies
renouvelables les défis sont nombreux
l europe doit dès maintenant se préparer
à changer en profondeur la manière dont
elles produits consomment et transporte
l'énergie pour cela les pays doivent
agir de manière cohérente mais où est la
cohérence dans votre politique
la société d'état edf vient de remporter
un contrat remarquable en grande
bretagne pour construire deux paires
développer le nucléaire
en accord avec le gouvernement français
actionnaire d'edf
serait-il bon pour la grande bretagne
mais pas pour la france concernant les
hydrocarbures de schiste
la france se prive aujourd'hui du droit
même d'explorer et dans le même temps
gdf suez à 34% propriété de l'état
acquiert une participation dans 13
permis d'exploration en grande-bretagne
incohérences ou hypocrisie
la future loi de programmation sur
l'énergie annoncée initialement pour mi
2013 devrait être adopté pour fin 2014
incohérences ou indécision l'énergie est
un des points forts de notre industrie
l'efficacité énergétique un pilier d'une
croissance plus vertueuses et créatrice
d'emplois
quels sont vos objectifs votre volonté
votre cap
s'agit-il d'être otage d'une composante
de votre majorité bien fragile la france
enfin ghz et 3 fois 20 pour 2020
mais que fait-on concrètement pour les
atteindre il n'est qu'à voir ce qui se
passe avec la politique et les
atermoiements aujourd'hui pour les
certificats d'économie d'énergie
incohérence indécision atermoiements
dans cette cacophonie
quelle peut être la contribution de la
france à la politique énergétique
européenne
merci monsieur le ministre philippe
martin le président monsieur sénateurs
us ont merci de me donner finalement la
possibilité de vous dire deux trois mots
sur la logique de la politique qui est
menée parce que la logique de
l'immobilisme celle de ne rien faire
sera celle qui aboutira en matière
énergétique au renchérissement sans fin
du coût de l'énergie à une facture
énergétique porté par les ménages qui
sera insupportable et qui ruinera la
compétitivité des entreprises
la politique que vous avez menées qui
est celle de ne jamais traiter la
question de l'énergie de ne jamais osé
faire un débat national sur la
transition énergétique
comme nous l'avons fait de vouloir
rénover notre mix énergétique et ne pas
simplement laisser au fil de l'eau les
énergies se renchérir avec des
augmentations sans fin pour les ménages
et pour les entreprises eh bien nous
nous voulons faire le contraire nous
nous voulons que l'état soit stratège
nous nous voulons effectivement une
politique de transition énergétique qui
fasse que les énergies renouvelables
soient beaucoup plus forte
et s'agissant des gaz de schiste et
cette loi du 2 2 2011 votée à
l'initiative de votre excellent confrère
de l'ump monsieur jacob puisque c'est
quand même bien lui qui aujourd'hui nous
traitent d'obscurantistes alors que
c'est lui qui a fait cette loi
eh bien je me félicite pourra que le
conseil constitutionnel ait donné raison
en droit et sur la forme à cette loi qui
interdit d'aller encore un peu plus vers
des énergies fossiles dont nous n'avons
pas besoin il faut changer d'ère
monsieur husson et changer d'air
ça n'est pas complaire à une formation
politique c'est penser au pays
penser aux générations futures et la
politique du gouvernement c'est celle
qui justement prépare à l'avenir des
générations futures
merci alors monsieur jean françois
husson
oui monsieur le ministre
j'entends le procès en immobilisme et au
fait que vos prédécesseurs n'aurait rien
fait dieu merci et les uns les autres
ont pu constater notamment que les
effets des différentes lois grenelle se
font aujourd'hui sentir et ressentir
voilà ça a été souvent souligné donc
premier élément deuxième élément j'ai
été surpris et je me suis interrogé
quand vous avez déclaré tout à l'heure
que l'énergie était à l'ordre du jour de
l'agenda européen sur la proposition et
grâce au présent république
écoutez puisse-t-il en sortir cette fois
des décisions fortes et concrètes pour
notre avenir et enfin puisque je suis
sur le concret sur les certificats
d'économie d'énergie qui répondent aux
trois fois 20 je vous mets monsieur le
ministre je vous demande pardon de bien
vouloir intervenir auprès du pôle
national parce que les des territoires
notamment le mien le seul celui dont je
suis élu sur le grand nancy où plus de
mille aujourd'hui dossiers de
particuliers d'entreprises attendent
attendent d'être traités
c'est aujourd'hui ressenti comme étant
inacceptable inadmissible je compte donc
sur votre prompte et efficace
intervention très bien mes chers
collègues je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi pour l'accès
au logement et à l'urbanisme rénover la
séance est suspendue
voilà vous avez pu suivre en direct de
l'hémicycle la séance de questions
cribles des questions qui ont consacré à
la politique énergétique européenne
on se retrouve dans quelques instants
pour la suite de l'examen du projet de
loi sur le logement